priests with ready face of God are tall
so what the rest of the world knows has
the faceless man
you said you teach me how to be a
faceless man a man teaches a girl well I
do iris Oh men must serve faceless men
most of all it's a small religion they
are not themselves gods they are the
servants of the god of many faces and
the ones he wants to deemed killed they
give the gift of death - there is only
one God that God knows his name nor men
know his gift they're supposed to put
aside any previously conceives or love
they they love no one they hate no one
they are no one I am ready to be a
faceless man to be no one they may
assume many Dame's they may have so many
faces but you know among themselves when
they say who are you the answer is no
one I'm no one
I'm an instrument of God that's all a
blade in his hand and my desires in this
world don't matter it's just I exist to
serve the God and to give the gift whose
thought is that it belongs to higher
stock how is it that no one came to be
surrounded by ayah starts things needle
the last link to Winterfell and are yet
the faceless men want her to give it up
because they recognize its importance
but she can't quite give it up if she
are you anymore a long time ago she
started out as Arya and she became Arry
the orphan boy I mean how many names as
she had over the course of the years
since she's fled King's Landing a lot of
them where are you from my temple if
he's become a changeling who changes to
fit in who who has to adopt new names
and new personas at every step along the
way this is just the ultimate end of
that process
our Yahoo's expected to absorb the ethos
of the faceless men she becomes a novice
and then eventually an acolyte and they
begin to drain her she's being taught
certain arts of assassination through a
series of apprenticeships at the house
of black and white oh yeah
it's very skilled in some of these
things that picks them up very quickly
but there are aspects to her that are
not as successful was that true
well did you believe every word I said
if you're gonna kill somebody
quickly and efficiently you have to be a
good liar and you have to be able to
tell when someone is lying to you
you have to learn to recognize these
clues and others but also to control
these tells in yourself my family home
is Winterfell youngest daughter for
Great Lord Eddard Stark
he died in battle my Aria plays this
game where they tell things to each
other and the other one has to judge is
that a lie is that the truth that you
just told me she slowly gets more
proficient at it it is a test the
faceless men have a sorceress procedure
for changing your face I'll use a phases
of the Dead which day skin off their
victims and hang up to dry and then when
they want to become that person they
pull the skin over their own face she's
having a very hard time letting go of
those last remnants of Arya but where
else does she have to turn that girl is
not ready to become no one
but she's ready to become someone else
who are the faceless men it depends on
who is asking to a penitent they may be
relief to evict him they may be
vengeance to a lord they may be an
incredible expense and to the iron bank
they may be just another asset nobody
but the faceless men know their origin
that the order is rumored to predate the
founding of Braavos we know only that
they reside in or are somehow aligned
with the house of black and white at alt
and lonely building a few who enter ever
leave some whisper that those where wood
doors open not on a house but on to the
world of the dead from whence the
faceless men rise when summoned we can
dismiss such foolishness as we do the
fishwives who spread it the house of
black and white is merely a temple
consecrated to the many-faced God and
filled with statuary of his many faces
the old gods of Westeros the Lord of
Light the Black Goat the Lion of night a
weeping lady a stranger perhaps now you
understand what is worshiped here and
along with them other gods hunan alive
now recognize brought here long ago by
sailors never came again unlike the
priests of other religions the servants
here preached no sermons and performed
no ceremonies as far as one can see
silence and solitude from the whole of
their worship as well as collecting the
occasional devotee if one wants to
engage a faceless man one visits the
house of black and white and pays the
price as for what that may be those who
have paid it rarely speak of it for make
no mistake from the moment the faceless
men accept your offer
the man you named is dead though he
doesn't know
perhaps not that day perhaps not that
year but soon and inevitably many would
say you are as much his murderer as if
you'd swung an axe yourself just as many
would say that's the point